[Music]
try chronovirus coverage here at noon
now at a new vaccine site open today in
henderson as more and more people become
eligible to get their shots here in
nevada
this one's located at sun city anthem
community center and we have hector
mejia they're live
with a look inside hi hector
[Music]
hey there and it's really taking an
entire community to run these operations
to my left this is the check encounter
for volunteers who
not only help with the clerical side but
they also disinfect things like counter
seats high
touch areas what's also unique here is
that sun city anthem has its own covet
19 task force
this is the second time this place has
been offering the covid vaccine
the city of henderson and sun city
anthem partnered up to offer 800 daily
doses for the next
six weeks appointments open to anyone as
long as they meet the requirements under
the southern nevada health district
for the first three weeks people can get
the first dose of the pfizer vaccine
the second dose will be administered to
those same patients during the following
three weeks
these efforts we're told are even more
special when we remember that the site
is mostly run by about 400
local volunteers majority of these
people up here aren't getting a paycheck
they're up here doing it for the right
reasons because they want to help
you know and covet and move on from this
pandemic and you know
get back to normalcy so they're up here
just volunteering their time
coming out meeting new people smiling
volunteers are also keeping the overall
cost down for the city
a lot of these folks are socializing for
the first time in months after being
isolated at home
and that's a benefit they did not
necessarily anticipate coming into these
operations
as a task force they said they said they
were concerned over
mental health aspects of the kobe 19
disaster so that's a plus
that we see on members of the community
here interacting safely and they're open
from 8 a.m to 2 p.m
you can make an appointment through the
southern nevada health district's
website or
the city of henderson reporting from
henderson hector mejia
8 news now